good morning the wipers are free care
how do i turn the windshield wipers and
then 735 we are late we were supposed to
leave earlier than this how are you we
said we'd be leaving 720 but it is 735
so we are late two minutes yeah which
isn't good but we'll see what we can do
I figure if i drive like crazy anyway we
woke up well it was still dark and
there's something wrong with setting an
alarm to wake up before you wake up when
you're at home to go to work but we're
here and we're ready to go to magic
kingdom and Hayden's already what do you
want to say oh you're silly now okay
here we are buddy Walt Disney World with
Mickey and Minnie disney world where
dreams come true leenon hatin are going
to line up at the mine train there's a
castle and I'm going to get us some
coffee starbucks
all right first up is the seven doors
mine train what do we think about the
mine train we had a bit of a fun ride
getting here Nina was in line and then
and then stepped out of line because I
didn't know if you had the best so our
whole I'll get the coffee while you
stand in line plane got destroyed
because I came here I come to the front
of the line like Oh Nina sent me here
Nina's foot and I walked back and then
you're still not there Oh name is not
even in line it's okay though we're
still here a little bit early here we go
we're on the mine train
what's up gonna go again got to deal
with this we'll see how it goes okay
next up Winnie the Pooh let's see how we
do says 30 minutes I'm a little scared
of a being in the slide the great thing
about the Disney rides are all the fun
things you get to do in line to make the
lineups go faster and Lena has her five
toe shoes on to catching ten o'clock and
Nina has already taken three thousand
seven hundred steps it says oh this is a
good job but that is a good job such
gold all your goals in okay so we're
going to hit that let's get on board
that's it
that was good huh yeah okay next up is
the Barnstormer with goopy as the great
you fini goofy is a crazy driver next up
is Dumbo it in come on this way we're
look this way come out all right come on
come on come on silly go the wrong way
go follow Nina here we go
right Hayden has his necklace anywhere
he has to give to them so they marked
the time they know how long the line is
so I have to make a quick note have to
make a quick note about the taurine
finds a nap this thing is amazing so as
you go through you click on the done and
at least to the next thing it's right
now 10 17 and we're supposed to be at
dumbo at 1031 so we are actually ahead
of schedule and rocking it we haven't
had to wait in line too much and highly
recommend this app
and this is Nina oh we're going up I got
a kiss-up I don't have a control this
thing oh here we go I'm going out right
I'm going I'm going I'm catching up yeah
there we go I cut up all right next up
Little Mermaid
next up is the Mad Hatter's Tea Party
hopefully this has been too fast Megan
Disney's see what happens
focus on you I'm looking at here that's
it it's crazy how we feeling
busy are you feeling hating you dizzy
wow you're good next up for us the
Tomorrowland Speedway my favorite part
is watching Nina and Hayden drive
together it'll be amazing here we go
don't strike so I hands of course going
straight to what do you think mr.
what
I did love you I did it on purpose to go
camping
so why did that info
I don't know I just broke the rules
alright last ride before lunch is the
carousel do some more stock riding move
Nina's never been on a carousel is your
first time
right it's lunch time with Pinocchio and
we're having what's that indeed in
heaven you having pretty happy
pepperoni pizza with yogurt and water
and grapes he is having an Italian
flatbread sup I'm having bocconcini
something
I'm starving and getting angry I'm on
the verge of angry so I'm going to get
some napkins and deacon okay with good
planning and fast eating we have more
time than rich of the point so we're
going to go see it's a small world we
were supposed to see it the next time on
day three but we're here Oh what what
are you saying that he's a girl okay
great that is a girl thank you for that
in the middle of my video mr. we're
going to go see it's a small world and
I'm sure we'll be singing all the way
welcome to the happiest cruise that ever
sailed
you
next up Peter Pan and instead of
spending 60 minutes in line as it says
on the sign there we get fast pass
let's get better
that fine can you pretend to be captain
huh up next Mickey's Philharmonic next
up people mover
next up monsters inc left floor or
inside of the monsters inc to learn some
comedy maybe Hayden's going to tell us a
joke knock knock who's there
hey
next up Buzz Lightyear we're going to go
inside and shoot a bunch of stuff so I
don't think I'll be able to fill much
are you excited to shoot things yeah how
you gonna shoot it hanging a few let's
eat like that huh yeah yeah this is what
we're going on time to shoot some
cannons and wouldn't hammer away cuz I
got a dominate I got a dominate read
what is this I can't shoot anything 76
921 I'd hate into had it hey tin THU 23
I got 76 there's behaving there's me
that's game face right there that is
game face hidden with the evil Emperor
Zurg bra we are done the right portion
of our day
almost three o'clock waiting for the new
parade that just came out festival so I
decided that while we wait we should get
some
starbucks because i haven't even had
established we're here at the magic
kingdom outside the castle we're waiting
for festival of dancing hayden is on the
boat
yeah what do you play fieldrunners
okay well we wait for the parade okay
the parade is about to start you hear
the music
do I look happy
so we're done everything for the day and
it's time to go shopping and explore
Main Street and the first thing humbled
on is this crystal maker who is making
crystal here on the spot with his
ginormous flame it's pretty cool Linda
deal with Hayden because when you have
kids in the store they want to buy
everything I'm going to deal with him
that he could have one thing new trip
and he's but unlike in two days in a row
it's a magic key right it started off as
a wizard Mickey then it became a magic
wand and now become a magic key all in
one day that's it
come back from back there you go why do
you like that key what kind of special
powers wow so he has to like it for two
days in a row and then we'll buy but
it's probably gonna find the other thing
is that he liked so we'll see how wide
you buy the mug his last time I bought
one and then [ __ ] foster
this one it's really cute then the back
that's already
and it shipped here so I need a new one
this is for you
okay morning are magical okay like
negative side it is a little negative
this one mini all right you can read
that what does it say
Disney gift card good job mr. reading at
five years old huh high five for that
Booya I've discovered in heaven and of
Jason Swiss Army knife right below Jason
I love all the fun shirts that you can
find here at the stores okay we made it
back what we're gonna do it feels nice
to have the shoes off yeah so it's a
relax eat shower maybe two showers for
me whoo oh and why oh this is my
favorite wine barefoot i'm not a huge
wine drinker but this is really sweet so
we're gonna start for blind tonight
these are our wine glasses okay here we
go I need I need the shade to to get
along okay Cheers it's like ice wine
yeah
she kills our fashion oh oh no he's
hiding okay it's eight o'clock it's
eight o'clock Hayden's bedtime we're
gonna have a good sleep wake up tomorrow
go to epcot see figment have some fun
some special surprises okay did you have
fun today what was your favorite part of
today that was roller coasters and Buzz
Lightyear for those of you who couldn't
understand it okay so we'll see you
tomorrow bye good night so Nina thinks
that I need a haircut so this is me
before and this is the actor what do you
think self-improvement books are like
fitness books they never work on their
own what you need is a trainer that's
Evan get the newsletter
you